[Musique]
bonjour serge papin soir le grand public
vous connaît peu en revanche tout le
monde connaît lé en scène que vous avez
dirigé pendant près de 15 ans et système
u alors vous êtes un patron très
atypique parce que tout ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui dans la
grande distribution
eh bien vous l'aviez prédit que ce soit
les dérives de la surconsommation
que ce soit la fin des hypers tels qu'on
les connaît aujourd'hui
ce soit le retour au terroir où
l'explosion du bio alors on va voir avec
vous comment vous en êtes arrivé là mais
pour commencer je voudrais vous montrer
l'image d'un homme qui vous a beaucoup
inspiré
regardez qu'ils sont finalement non
nocivité se nourrir se vêtir s'abriter
soigne t tout il reste après tout le
système engendre une frange du superflu
qui est considérable même dans la
production bas 30 % de ce que nous
produisons servat ne servent à rien
alors vous êtes fans de pierre rabhi
alors que vous étiez patron de la grande
distribution c'est quand même été aux
antipodes de ce que vous êtes j'ai fait
une conférence à une pierre avis nous
étions à lyon devant sept ou huit cents
jeunes à l'université lyon et j'ai
appris à le connaître
et alors ce qui m'a inspiré chez lui
c'est ici souvent cette anecdote
africaine où il ya le feu dans la forêt
le colibri arrive avec sa goutte d'eau
et c'est d'état de la 110ème le tapis
revient et ça sert à rien ce que tu fais
et le colibri dit mais je prends ma part
j'ai ce que dit pierre rabhi il y au
fond si chacun prend sa part ben la
somme des parties va faire qu'on peut
peut-être changer le tout et ça je me
suis dit qu'en l'écoutant
voilà une leçon qui est intéressante et
je me dis qu'elle part je vais prendre à
sa part pour plus de vertu et compris
dans les temples de consommation tels
que ceux que vous avez dirigé oui alors
comment arriver aussi à consommer mieux
c'est ça aussi je me suis toujours dit
que quand on veut détourner un avion il
faut être dedans du système est plutôt
que parfois hurler à côté c'est comment
on peut essayer de changer les choses et
c'est pas parce que je vois je mettais
en marché des produits où j'en étais
responsable qu'on pouvait pas mettant en
marché des produits plus vertueux
c'était ça a été ma quête si on peut
dire
alors vous vous êtes issu d'une famille
de commerçants en vendée vos parents
tenait une petite épicerie quand vous
étiez enfant et le truc justement c'est
que vous ne vouliez absolument pas
devenir commerçant comme vos parents
plus tard bon ben moi j'ai vécu ce
métier de petit à petit épicier donc on
et magasins étaient ouverts de 7h le
matin en deux heures et on n'avait pas
de vie de famille puisque ou très peu un
puisque voilà on était disponible pour
les clients et je voyais mes parents
travailler beaucoup et je suis bon au
fond est ce que tout ça a du sens et en
souffriez peut-être un peu oui peut-être
devoir qui avait peut-être pas assez de
comment dire de disponibilité pour la
famille pour pour les enfants et bien
sûr il n'y a pas eu aucun reproche
mais je trouvais que ce métier était un
métier de labeur et de et de services de
disponibilité
donc je dis oh là là je ferais jamais ça
une version wii tutorat roger wills
jacques à l'époque ou alors en même
temps à l'école ben c'est pas vraiment
ça puisque vous êtes exclu du pensionnat
la fin d'un troisième jeu
alors en fait j'ai je crois que j'ai
essayé de chercher pourquoi tout ça est
en fait je me suis dit que j'étais
rebelle à toute forme d'autorité
d'ailleurs au fond j'avais ça en tête
quand j'étais gamin je me dis bon il
faut que je veux pas être embêté il faut
plutôt que choix devant comme ça au
moins on n'a pas de comptes à rendre ce
qu'il a fait sans doute que j'ai
toujours voulu un peu de ce point de vue
là faire la course en tête mais je
n'arrivais pas qu'il faut se rappeler du
contexte on était moi quand je rentre au
pensionnat saint joseph à
fontenay-le-comte on est en 68 dans
l'ouest de la france
en vendée on est en 68 il ya un esprit à
vent nouveau qui souffle où je suis
complètement mois intéressé par ça parce
que on quitte une fois on essaie de
quitter une société très patriarcales et
et moi je rentre dans ce qui me semblait
être une prison alors même que peut-être
on a envie de s'y est justement les
barreaux qu'on a les institutions comme
l'éducation nationale pour vous et et
étouffante
oui pis le modèle aussi le modèle
sociétal
il faut se rappeler de cette époque-là
de ce contexte et donc je ne me sentais
pas à l'aise et donc ma façon obligé pas
envie d'être là simplement j'ai pas
envie d'être uni se troue bas il ya un
petit collège pas très loin de chez moi
où on pouvait être allait venir
retourner chez soi il ajouté en pensiez
vous avez un besoin de liberté besoin de
liberté et puis donc ça me convenait pas
donc je me rebelle et vous quittez
l'école je suis renvoyé à vous être
envoyé
donc vous allez faire un bep et puis on
veut bien après et puis vous allez
devenir manutentionnaire dans une grande
enseigne intermarché en espace vous êtes
donc manutentionnaires quand vous êtes
très très jeune qu'est ce que vous
retenez de cette expérience
alors je rentre dans cet internat j'ai
17 ans j'ai passé en effet mon bep
commerce
voilà et mon père dit bon avoir essayé
de te trouver un petit job avant de
faire le service militaire
voilà et je rentre à l'intermarché de
fontenay comme manu tu as besoin 0 mais
ont soulevé des cartons
de l'arrière au magasin et j'en tiens
expérience que moi ça ça m'a appris la
solidarité des scoops rappelé voilà des
petites gens enfin dans le commerce que
vous allez découvrir des années plus
tard j'ai ptet je me rappelle je
mangeais le midi dans un restaurant
ouvrier excellent paient ou moi on était
dans univers où il y avait des gens des
ouvriers toutes les entreprises et j'ai
apprise en faisait partie
bien sûr et j'ai appris la solidarité
pierrine entraide
je ne veux pas dire que la grande
distribution par la suite s'est montré
particulièrement généreux et
particulièrement social surprise entendu
on voit le temps partiel subi deux
caissières pas rêver mais d'accord guy
lagache mais moi je leur présente un
milieu de commerçants indépendants
il y à de nombreux commerçants
indépendants qui ont envie d'avoir un
progrès social dans l'entreprise qu'il
dirige
c'est un ce sont leurs fruits a eu ça ça
vous l'avez rappelé jean vous étiez
vous-même ouvriers exactement la grèce
est pour ça que j'ai influencé après
pour faire en sorte par exemple d'aller
vers dés contrat d'intéressement de
faire en sorte quand vous étiez pas trop
ce qu'est exactement d'éviter le temps
partiel subi
ce soit que du temps partiel choisi il
est arrivé que mon état et un système
que je pense pas parfaitement pas
parfaite mais en tous les cas j'ai
poussé vers ça même si j'ai eu parfois
de l'opposition et sur la répartition
des résultats j'ai poussé à ce qui est
systématiquement des contrat
d'intéressement pour que 20 à 30% des
résultats soit donnée aux collaborateurs
donc on voit d'où ça vient
voilà et d'ailleurs je me suis aperçu au
passage que les entreprises les plus
productives des plus performantes chu
c'était celle qu'ils paient mieux leurs
personnels qui distribue les résultats
et qui vendait aussi les moins chers et
c'est celle là qui paradoxalement avec
plus de rentabilité
alors retour de votre service militaire
vous allez faire une école pour devenir
chef de rayon sur les conseils de votre
père c'est assez étrange parce que vous
détestez le commerce d'un côté et vous
mettez les deux pieds dedans oui après
alors moi j'avais aussi alors je plie ou
en revenant de l'armée fille bon il faut
quand même que je fasse quelque chose
j'ai envie de retrouver mon père je me
suis opposé et que mon père étant jeune
scout héros belge était non seulement à
l'école mais c'était aussi un peu contre
lui est donc là j'écoute mon père mon
père m'a dit écoute tu vas aller à split
école qui dure six mois pour être chef
de rayon pas que ça plaît et tu verras
ça va tout ouvrir sont des possibilités
puis on est à l'époque où la grande
distribution est naissante est donc là
je me dis tiens il ya peut-être quelque
chose de nouveau alors justement
regardons ces images
oui parce qu'on est à la fin des années
60 est une révolution a lieu dans le
commerce
[Musique]
c'est moi
je suis
je fais des ballons
[Musique]
thiney
il n'a pas les bousculer l'univers
[Musique]
vous rentrez d'engomer c'est ça que vous
découvrez ces malveillances que c'est un
fait mais ont depuis disparu d'un convoi
mammuth montréal et c'est bien sûr parce
que il faut se rappeler le contexte de
l'époque où nous sommes dans les années
70 on n'est pas aussi loin que ça de la
fin de la disette de la guerre et
finalement le la grande distribution est
le reflet de l'époque l'époque à a envie
la société envie de consommer a envie de
de jouir
si on peut dire est ce assez représentée
par par la grande distribution qui est
l'exemple et alors il y avait au petit
il faut imaginer des petites boutiques
qui distribue les produits de
consommation qui sont très chers
l'arrivée des hypermarchés et quand les
hypermarchés arrive des supermarchés
arrive
moi je me souviens d'ouvertures de
magasins qu'on faisait je suis pas par
exemple à ploërmel en bretagne mais les
jo le soir quand on distribuait comme ça
des petits cadeaux à la fin de la
journée mais les gens presque nous
embrassait en disant que c'est
formidable ça change et ça a changé la
vie des gens à l'époque il faut se
rappeler de ça après il ya eu sans doute
vexé d'être amère mais dans les années
70 enfin rappelez vous quand leclerc
ouvre à landerneau son magasin en
bretagne parce que yvon ce qu'on appelle
au prix de gros yvan le détail -au prix
des grossistes donc c'est moins 20% mois
celle habituellement y aller il ya les
caméras de pierre des groupes de cinq
colonnes à la une qui sont à l'ouverture
de ce magasin et de l'autre côté il ya
le sais pas si vous rappeler de ça 2 le
cidunati aider pierre poujade qui est la
plus les crs rendez compte on a les
plaques tectoniques des modernes qui
s'affrontent
c'est un type qui est en train d'arriver
dans le commerce traditionnel c'est
aussi disruptif à l'époque que l'est le
digital et son sac et c'est ça qui fait
que vous
vous décidez d'aller dans le commerce
alors c'était au départ un rejet oui
parce que j'ai l'impression d'être là où
il faut être dans la modernité de mon
époque
alors vous allez gravir tous les
échelons de l'entreprise au sein de
système u puisque vous êtes repéré par
le patron de l'enset de système u et
vous allez mener cette guerre
cette nouvelle concurrence qui avec ses
enseignes que sont auchan carrefour
leclerc vous en parliez et ça va se
jouer évidemment sur les prix les prix
bar oui comment vous faites pour mener
la guerre des prix alors que vous même
vous êtes au sein de systèmes
d'abord je tiens à dire qu'on nous on
est parti bien après les autres familles
l'an dernier un juge jean claude jenet
mon prédécesseur prend en 75 la décision
de la laisser à le supermarché leclerc
premier de clerck est ouvert et donc on
est en haut des bus où on est fin d
année enfin début des années 60 quand on
a 15 ans de retard donc il faut vraiment
que vous alliez sera guerre des prix
alors il faut aller sur les prix il faut
convaincre d comme des ex petits
commerçants qui sont de baisser les prix
je lui ai alors comment est ce qu'on
fait est bien
on essaie d'abord de négocier avec les
grandes marques avec les grandes marques
ce qui n'est pas facile
une grande marque et que j'ai pas
rabaisser mépris vous faites comment oui
et puis nous ne sommes pas les plus
puissants de savoir quelle époque on
fait je suis pas 20% du chiffre
d'affaires de carrefour
quel premier donc comment est ce qu'on
fait voilà ce qu'il faut être malin dans
ces cas là eh bien on se positionne
comme la grande surface de la petite
ville nous on est venue des petits
bourgs et cd ancien boucher des anciens
boulangers des petits épiciers qui ont
monté leur supermarché en supermarché et
on offre ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
maillage territorial dans la france
rurale la france des petites villes qui
intéresse des grands groupes comme
nestlé comme coca cola commune et le
vert
parce que ils vont pouvoir diffuser
leurs produits y compris dans les
campagnes mais c'est sans parfois les
négociations alors voilà alors donc on
essaie de vendre autre chose que la
puissance d'achat parce que la puissance
d'achat on n'aurait pas le vol par
contre par contre on a des informations
aussi sur par exemple des différences de
prix que pourrait nous faire certaines
grandes marques entre leclerc carrefour
et nous et là on le voit bien si on est
disqualifié c'est à ce moment là quelque
chose qui qui qui fait qu'on peut perdre
la face visible reste un client la
raison d'être ce que l'on a fait à
l'époque on a usé de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler aujourd'hui de déréférencement
mais aussi on a dit à des industriels
adema con las d'écouter
si vous voulez pas tenir compte de notre
spécificité
on va pas travailler donc ça veut dire
des références et c'est à dire que si
j'accepte pas votre prix et que je suis
une grande marque que vous me dites vous
serez pas dans mes rayons comme j'ai eu
c'est ça écoutez ça gâche moi je vous
assure j'ai
des preuves que des marques vis-à-vis de
lui à l'époque on s'appelait unico avait
des écarts entre 5 et 10%
comment vous voulez faire avec les
concurrents les concurrents donc on a
dit bon ok fait beau jamais senti le
produit on a sorti deux comme quoi par
exemple cette grande marque de soda ça
nous est arrivé là car j'ai par exemple
oui oui parce que il s'alignait pas sur
les prix que vous vouliez parce que il
ne considérait pas comme des gens aussi
important que les grandes enseignes de
type carrefour ou auchan pas et donc
c'est sur nes et négociations pour avoir
les prix les plus bas possibles que
petit à petit vous êtes devenus parmi
les grandes enseignes nationales alors
devenir la troisième quatrième enseigne
de supermarchés aujourd'hui vue et la
troisième enseigne de supermarchés
cinquième groupe au plan national
oui parce qu'on a voulu situer nos
coeurs du discount on peut pas il faut
qu'on soit dans le peloton
dans ce métier là si vous n'êtes pas
compétitif vous n'existez pas alors les
les prix bas jusqu'au je voudrais qu'on
qu'on regarde cette image là qu'on
s'arrête sur cette image
serge papa
[Musique]
non c'était pendant mayer
c'était il ya quelques années des gens
qui se battent pour avoir un pot de
nutella vendu 70 % moins cher que son
prix initial dans une grande enseigne et
ça c'est la caricature de tous les excès
parce que là on est sur un prix qui est
une opération de com et je la recherche
du prix à tout prix et bien moi j'ai
vite vu qu'on allait en payer le prix
et pourtant désirent participer vous
mais j'ai rapidement compris qu'il
fallait passer du prix qu'on pourrait
appeler prédateurs à un prix responsa
c'est un prix prédateur fin oui c'est un
prix c'est d'une opération de com je
rappelle juste au passage que quand
intermarché a sorti cette opération nous
étions en train de discuter autour des
états généraux de l'alimentation pour
cadrer les promotions pour réduire enfin
ça c'est un prix de provocation de là
est ce que est ce qu'on se dit pas quand
on est patron de la grande distrib comme
vous l'êtes patron de la grande
distribution qu'on a participé à
fabriquer un monstre à force d'aller
chercher des prix les plus bas
à un moment il faut avoir un regard
global sur l'ensemble d'une filière
évidemment si on fait porter sur le
maillon le plus faible
là les inconvénients si on peut dire de
la ou les conséquences de la guerre des
prix est bien on en portera on emporte
les responsabilités quand par exemple
c'est les paysans qui sont les maillons
plus faibles et que l'appareil
de l'appareil agricole se subit cette
guerre des prix et ne n'arrive pas à
s'en sortir il faut signer l'armistice
et en même temps nous d'achat du
consommateur
ça reste très très haut mais attendez
vous allez voir donc moi je suis rentré
très vite à partir de 2017
on s'est mis en place ce qu'on appelle
la loi de modernisation de l'économie
lme
cette loi a été fait pour faire baisser
les prix mission accomplie mais à quel
prix
regardez ce qui se passe au niveau des
agriculteurs donc il faut revenir à ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le prix
responsable je vais vous citer un
exemple j'ai eu des discussions avec les
éleveurs de l'élevage de boeuf en france
ou au ps pour donner un exemple 3 euros
50 le kilo de viande en carcasse
s'ajouter le prix face quel prix un peu
prédateurs on a discuté on a on fit
combien il faut pour que vous vous en
sortiez bien est facile produits de
qualité il fallait un euro de plus à
l'achat
4 euros 50 donc ce qu'on a fait moi j'ai
vu mes engagements je vous dis attendez
conséquences pour le consommateur sur
inspectent 250 g 4 centimes d'euro
toute la question maintenant qui va
falloir se poser est ce que on n'est pas
capable d'accepter légèrement une petite
hausse pourrait encourager soit la moins
sanglante possible pour le citoyen
encourager nos concitoyens à manger
moins sans doute à manger mieux et pour
faire en sorte que l'alimentation
réconcilie avec la santé avec
l'environnement avec la rémunération du
producteur
est-ce que c'est pas une alimentation
réconciliatrice plutôt qu'une
alimentation qui est dans le rapport de
force parce que quand vous voyez la
fameuse pâte à tartiner
ld forest avec huile de palme et les
conséquences environnementales axa la
santé sur gazon voilà alors que quel
prix il faut payer alors je vois la
voiture quand est ce que vous avez pris
conscience vous personnellement des
dérives
à cette guerre des prix et donc de la
grande distribution que vous
personnellement vous en êtes vraiment
rendu coup moi j'avais d'abord j'avais
en moi enfin toute ma jeunesse un peu
entre guillemets un peu hippie un peu
bon donc j'avais un peu ces choses là
c'est bien cette sensibilité pis j'ai
perdu mon père très jeune il est mort
d'un cancer
il avait 58 ans et mon père jamais fait
jamais faire d'excès et je me suis dit
mais que peu comment ça c'est possible
trouver ça profondément injuste et avec
ma mère on s'est intéressés d'un peu
plus près à toutes ces questions et on a
vite vu qu'il y avait un lien entre
alimentation et santé et je suis allé
plus loin donc quand j'ai pris la tête
de système u je me suis dit au fond qui
met en marché des produits il faut que
je puisse être me regarder dans la glace
des scouts et là j'ai fait faire une
enquête sur ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les substances controversé soit ces
produits toxiques à l'intérieur de notre
talent voilà j'ai demandé à un ingénieur
qui s'appelle maximilien rouer qui j'ai
relevé tous les produits à la limmat se
trouvait 90 produit 90 substance et vous
exams est éliminé de marque distributeur
en 2005 je dis coûté on va enlever ça de
nos produits à notre marque
il y avait les phtalates le bisphénol
l'huile de palme l'aspartame raid à 90
on était les premiers à enlever le bas b
par exemple bien avant les grandes
marques de cosmétiques et bien
évidemment je me suis heurté à l'époque
ont dû mai courant à berne
on alterne c'est pas notre boulot nous
on est commerçant vend ce qui se vend on
a tenu les positions et aujourd'hui
c'est devenu un projet d'entreprise et
maintenant on voit bien tout le monde va
sur bare ce sujet là et je suis content
d'avoir initié un mouvement et donc moi
j'ai fait le lien entre mes convictions
de jeunesse ce que j'ai pu voir
malheureusement du décès de mon père est
le métier dans lequel j'étais est en
vous écrivez ce livre vous consommez
moins consommer mieux avec jean marie
avec jean marie pelt se tait c'est tout
à fait
à l'opposé de du métier oui la demande
hypermarchés oui je me suis laissée
marrant parce que quand je lis j'ai
sorti en 2009 y compris chez moi bon ça
a été perçu d'une manière pas forcément
toujours positive alors que moi je
percevais c'était une façon pour moi de
témoigner qu'on peut vivre mieux en
consommant moi vous avez cité pierre
rabhi tout à l'heure pierre rabhi
défense d'îles et de la sobriété
heureuse et je suis pas loin de penser
que la société 2030 et cela pas la cité
des années 80 et qu'on doit aller vers
plus de sobriété et en même temps
j'imagine qu'en interne les gens
devaient penser que vous jouiez contre
votre camp quand vous disiez par exemple
c'est la fin de l'existentialisme du
caddie le je consomme donc je suis est
déjà derrière nous et mais ils sont pas
hissé contre vous alors je vais vous
dire c'est une question de leadership
si vous êtes plus en résonance avec la
société et qu'à ce moment là en allant
sur ces terrains là vous trouvez une
résilience vous construisez un
leadership différents qu'ils soient sur
une forme de réconciliation et les gens
m'ont suivi pourquoi après parce qu'ils
sont aperçus que ça résonnait dans la
société ils sont dit tiens
serge et nous a provoqué au début ça a
été pas simple et après ils ont vu aussi
qu' il y avait une époque qui était
beaucoup plus concerné par par ces
enjeux là ils sont dix nous on va
construire à ce moment là autour de ça
un nouveau leadership et comment vous
voyez l'avenir des hypers aujourd'hui
les hypers ils sont dans ils
correspondent aux modèles des années 80
je pense que ils sont confrontés à la
fois à une consommation beaucoup plus
sobre donc ils sont ensuite qu'on ceux
concernés par la métropolisation puisque
il ya de moins en moins de salles et les
gens se concentrent dans les villes
alors les hyper développé en les référés
ville il faudra qu'ils posent un peu les
valises
et qui réinvente lippert des années 2030
donc c'est assez a repensé si vous étiez
patron du père aujourd'hui vous feriez
quoi je diminueraient sans doute un peu
les surfaces jeunes en plus peut-être
plus petits un peu je me spécialiserait
dans l'alimentation et j'irai sur le
fait entre guillemets le fait maison ou
le fait sur place
donc avec de l'animation à l'intérieur
et en essayant de faire un peu ce qu'ont
fait les grands magasins c'est une
espèce de shop in shop décor ne donne et
des corners des univers à jemmapes était
exactement
moi je j'aurai un lien avec les masses
espèce de paradoxes les marques ont
envie de ça va ça serait de rentrer avec
les marques dans un espèce de deux
contractualisme une théorie du contrat
mieux fait à durée indéterminée jeudi
seraient des liens avec les grandes
marques qui sont demanderesse de ça
demain serge papin demain pour vous
votre avenir c'est quoi écoutez j'ai
c'est d'accompagner des entreprises sur
ces terrains là nouveaux qui sont de de
percevoir ce changement d'époque
il ya un mot que j'aime bien je sais pas
si c'est un mot que je vais vous
apprendre ou si je vais apprendre à dos
téléspectateurs ça s'appelle la sonas
talent j
cela c'est juste un néologisme qui veut
dire la détresse psychologique de la
peur ben d'un changement de la peur
d'une angoisse sur l'avenir de la
société sur l'avenir du monde donc on a
des jeunes qui sont très inquiet c'est
un peu la génération greta et la société
civile les entreprises notamment
on était le problème il faut qu'elle
devienne la solution et vous là dedans
et moi je me sens intéressé pour
convaincre transmettent auprès des
dirigeants ce qui dès que comme disait
pascal de murs gère le président de la
maif il dit l'entreprise du 21e siècle
sera politique ou ne sera plus j'y crois
beaucoup et j'ai envie de convaincre
ceux qui
écoute les chefs d'entreprise de dire il
faut que vous rentriez vous aussi dans
cette dimension politique au sens noble
du terme la politique voulant dire
l'intérêt général merci infiniment
safina
[Musique]